We're asked to find the height
of a cylinder with a volume of
16 pi n to the fifth and a
base whose radius is 2n.
So just as a little bit of
review of how you find the
volume of a cylinder, let
me draw a cylinder here.
So if that is the top of my
cylinder and that is the
height of-- I'm not drawing
it as straight as I could.
If that is the height of my
cylinder and if this cylinder
was transparent and you could
see the base, which is just
like the top of it, It would
look something like that.
I should draw that second one
with a dotted line to show you
that you would only see it if
our cylinder was transparent.
That's our cylinder.
The volume of a cylinder, if
the height is h-- So if our
height of our cylinder is h, and
that if you had an area of
either the top or the bottom,
either the base of the top of
it of a, the volume of your
cylinder is going to be equal
to the height times the area
of the top or the base.
Depending on if you turn this
over, this would be the base.
Times the area of the base.
Now, what do they
tell us here?
We want to find the height.
They say find the height.
So we need to solve for h.
This is what we don't know.
Of a cylinder with a volume
of 16 pi n to the fifth.
So they tell us the volume.
They tell us the volume is
16 pi n to the fifth.
So that right there is
And then they tell us a base
whose radius is 2n.
So they're not telling
us the area, they're
telling us the radius.
They're telling us that this
radius right here is 2n right
over there.
Now, if you know the radius of
a circle, you know the area.
This top and the bottom,
these are circles.
That's what makes
it a cylinder.
These are circles.
So if you know the radius,
you know this area.
Area is equal to pi r squared.
One of the first things
we learn in geometry.
And so in this situation,
it would be equal to pi.
Our radius, they
tell us is 2n.
So pi times 2n squared.
And we know this is the same
thing, so area is equal to,
what is this? pi times
2 squared, which
is 4 times n squared.
4n squared.
Or if we just rearranged
it, area is
equal to 4 pi n squared.
So that's the area, that
right over there.
And so now we can solve for h.
We have 16 pi n to the fifth.
That's our volume.
That is equal to our height
times the area.
Times the area of the base or
the top of our cylinder.
Times 4 pi n squared.
Now, a good place to start if
we're trying to solve for h or
actually, it'll get us right
there immediately, is let's
divide both sides of this
equation by 4 pi n squared.
So you divide the right side
by 4 pi n squared.
Divide the left side
You have to do it
to both sides.
On the right-hand side,
these cancel out.
That was the whole point.
And you are left with h is equal
to this thing over here.
We can simplify this
a good bit.
We have a pi divided by a
pi, so those cancel out.
We have a 16 divided by 4,
that cancels out to a 4
divided by a 1, or just a 4.
And then you have n to the
fifth over n squared.
So when you have an exponent
in the denominator, you can
subtract it from the exponent
in the numerator.
So this is going to
be 4 right here.
Or 4/1.
I'll just write it as 4.
The pi's disappeared.
Times n to the 5 minus
2 power, which is 3.
n to the third power.
And we're done.
The height of the cylinder
is 4n to the third power.